today on the mat well show I want to
talk about a story from Stalin's Soviet
Russia
that seems harrowing ly relevant today
so we're gonna talk about that also five
headlines including the rampaging mob
tearing down a statue of Christopher
Columbus in Virginia and HBO banning
Gone with the Wind because it isn't
racially enlightened enough by our
standards today we have officially
entered the book-burning stage of our
societal collapse isn't it wonderful
and today in our daily cancellations
sadly tragically and my wife must be
cancelled again for the fifth time I
believe you will be outraged and and
truly scandalized when you hear what she
did so that's coming up as well now I
believe I've mentioned this story before
many shows ago so I apologize if I'm
repeating myself but I've been thinking
about this a lot especially recently
there's a book that I know I've
mentioned before and that's called The
Gulag Archipelago by Solzhenitsyn this
is his his masterwork his magnum opus
and he had a lot of great opuses oppai
maybe as the plural of that so it to say
this is his greatest really says
something indeed the Gulag Archipelago
is about the Soviet gulag system their
prison camp labor camp system and the
book it's three books actually three
volumes it covers several decades with a
significant focus especially in the
first volume on Stalin's reign over the
Soviet Union soldier Houston knew
something about the gulag system because
he spent a good amount of time in it he
went to a prison camp I think for seven
or eight years he suffered the same fate
as many Soviet soldiers did after coming
home from the front during World War two
after seeing some of the most brutal and
and and violent fighting in the war in
any war a lot of them came home and were
shipped off to prison camps on some you
know on one pretense or another there
were a reason was found many times to
send them back because of a suspicion
that the Soviet government had that
these people were you know may have
encountered Western ideas and so we need
to go in and sort of reset them
re-educate them by
to a prison camp the reason that
Solzhenitsyn was sent to prison camps
that he wrote some critical things about
Stalin in a private letter to a friend
and of course those writers letters were
intercepted in read and that's a big
no-no in a communist dictatorship you
don't say anything bad about the
Communist dictator and so he went to
prison camp for seven or eight years the
book is not a memoir though not
exclusively anyway it's it's also a
history of the labor camp system and of
Soviet Russia a chilling read highly
relevant highly relevant to our current
situation and I think one of the one of
the many failures of our public school
system is that high school kids are not
required to read all three volumes of
this book or even one volume of it one
of the many failures although I suppose
it makes sense I mean why would a prison
camp want its inmates to read a book
criticizing prison camps in any case
there are many stories from the gulag
archipelago that will haunt you and stay
with you after reading it one in
particular has been on my mind really
ever since I read the book but which was
a few years ago but especially in recent
months and especially in recent weeks I
have been thinking about this story an
incident is recounted that well actually
I guess I'll just I'll read it to you
I'll read I'm gonna read this passage
from the book so bear with me and before
we do that I want to tell you about our
friends at light stream you know saving
everything you can right now is is more
important than probably it's ever been
for a lot of money for a lot of people
that is including on your credit card
balance I mean you want to look for all
the areas of your life where you can
save money a lot of people are having to
tighten the belt in a lot of ways and
when you look at your credit card
balance there's an area where you could
save money you can get a credit card
consolidation loan from light stream and
you could save thousands in interest get
a rate as low as as 5.9 five percent APR
with Auto pay and excellent credit the
rate is fixed so it will never go up you
don't have to worry about that it's not
going to fluctuate over the life of the
loan plus there are absolutely no
fees so what you see is what you get
fixed-rate and you're good to go
you can even get your money in your bank
account as soon as the day you apply so
this is fast it's reliable low rate this
is why people love Lake Stream and if
you look at what the reviews what people
have to say about it you're gonna find
that people love it this is a great
opportunity you know if you have a
problem with your credit card debt it's
just something that weighs on people
when you when you have to be able that
I've dealt with it well light stream is
the way to go apply today to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream comm /
Waals Li ghts tream dot-com / Walsh
subject credit approval rate includes
0.5% auto pay discount terms and
conditions apply and offers are subject
to change without notice
visit light stream comm / Walsh for more
information all right so story from
Gulag Archipelago that really resonates
say let me read this to you
it says the district party conference
was underway at Moscow province it was
presided over by a new secretary of the
district party committee replacing one
recently arrested at the conclusion of
the conference a tribute to Comrade
Stalin was called for of course everyone
stood up the small Hall echoed with
stormy applause rising to an ovation for
three minutes four minutes five minutes
the storm Lee applause rising to an
ovation continued but palms were getting
sore and raised arms were already aching
and the older people were panting from
exhaustion that was becoming
insufferably silly even to those who
really adored Stalin however who would
dare to be the first to stop the
secretary of the district party
committee could have done it he was
standing on the platform and it was he
who had just called for the ovation but
he was a newcomer he had taken the place
of a man who'd been arrested he was
afraid
after all NKVD men were standing in the
hall applauding and watching to see who
quit first
and in that obscure small hall unknown
to the leader the applause went on six
seven eight minutes they were done for
their goose was cooked they couldn't
stop now till they collapsed with heart
attacks at the rear of the hall which
was crowded they could of course cheat a
bit clap less frequently less vigorously
not so eagerly but up there with the
Presidium where everyone could see them
the director of the local paper factory
independent and strong minded man stood
with the Presidium aware of all the
falsity and all the impossibility of the
situation he still kept on applauding
nine minutes ten in anguish he watched
the secretary of the district party
committee but the latter dared not stop
in sanity to the last man with
make-believe enthusiasm on their faces
looking at each other with faint hope
the district leaders were just going to
go on and on applauding until they fell
they were till they fell where they
stood till they were carried out on the
hall on stretchers and even then those
who were left would not falter then
after 11 minutes the director of the
paper factory assumed a businesslike
expression and sat down in his seat and
Oh a miracle took place where had the
universal uninhibited indescribable
enthusiasm gone to a man everyone else
stopped dead and sat down they had been
saved the squirrel had been smart enough
to jump off his revolving wheel that
however was how they discovered who the
independent people were and that was how
they went about eliminating them that
same night the factory director was
arrested they easily pasted ten years on
him on the pretext of something quite
different but after he had signed form
206 the final document of the
interrogation his interrogator reminded
him don't ever be the first to stop
applauding so there it is
don't ever be the
first to stop applauding that could be
the title of the book that some
historian one day writes about our
society and especially especially this
moment in our society we live in a
culture that demands we affirm
mainstream orthodoxy by performing ever
more elaborate displays of approval and
adulation is not enough to simply
tolerate the days of Tolerance are long
past which is why if you notice you
don't hear that word quite as much as
you used to because now it is
affirmation it is applause it is
pronouncements of your agreement and
your admiration that is what you're
required to provide tolerance will not
do it that's not going to cut it it's
not gonna be enough now we see this of
course with every item on the lefts
agenda particularly with anything
related to the sacred initialism LGBT
okay you can't simply tolerate the gay
pride parade you have to join it you
have to express your approval of it you
can't simply tolerate a man identifying
as a woman you must invite him into the
women's bathroom women's sports team you
must use whatever language he assigns
whatever whatever whatever pronouns he
demands the English language itself the
very rules of the English language must
be changed to accommodate him and on
down the list applaud join the chorus
don't stop don't sit down look at that
man in the dress what you you won't
cheer for him
you're not gonna chick tears of
admiration and joy are not welling up in
your eyes then you're a bigot you're a
dirtbag
you are Hitler incarnate and now we see
it especially with black lives matter
and this is what has really brought this
to the forefront of my mind you know
black lives matter an extremist
left-wing organization a violent
organization but we can't say any of
that I mean it's obviously true black
lives matter
protests all over the country have for
years to send it into anarchy and arson
and looting and murder but somehow we're
not allowed to point that out no no no
you can't do that
no and it's not just that you can't
point that out it's not just that you
can't point out how violent and
dangerous and wrong this organization is
about everything no no no you need to
kneel kneel before them literally kneel
before them in submission and worship
and then stand up and applaud whatever
they say whatever they demand agree
approve accept what a built burn down a
building want to burn down a police
precinct go right ahead and this is what
many people do this is what entire
companies billion-dollar companies do
they've been tripping over themselves to
throw their support behind the radical
left-wing agenda
black lives matter what about George
Floyd well it's not enough to say that
his death was unjustified that it's sad
that it's an injustice that it should be
adjudicated in court no no no no no that
that's not nearly enough you can't just
say that you again have to fall on your
knees and worship this man as a saint as
a hero as an icon and don't you dare
mention any of the of the of the shall
we say less savory aspects of George
Floyd's life don't mention that and this
is what's happening Democrats in the
house and knelt in silence to honor him
for eight minutes murals with his face
are spray painted are defacing in fact
buildings across the country he was
buried yesterday in a funeral attended
by hundreds even as many American
families have been prohibited from
holding funerals with more than 10 or 15
people and buried in a golden casket a
golden casket I'm not kidding
dignitaries and politicians showed up
from across the country to performative
Lee weep
over him here's the mayor of Minneapolis
who changed out of his wife's pants for
the occasion so I respect that at least
but here's here's him at George Floyd's
golden casket now I have been to plenty
of funerals as many of us have
unfortunately you don't often see that
sort of scene even from the family
members of the deceased okay but the
mayor and the mayor didn't didn't know
this man it's been weeks since this
occurred are we supposed to really
you're breaking down on the ground in
tears weeping again I you go to if you
go to if you you don't even usually see
that from family members at funerals not
not quite to that extent although of
course in their case would be totally
understandable but the mayor's playing
his part doing what he's told doing is
what is what's what's demanded of him
like a good boy
here's father James Martin heretic
priest literally canonizing George Floyd
in a tweet or trying to at least
it says the tweet says this is not a
great day for George Floyd who only
wanted to breathe or for his family or
friends who wanted him to live may mr.
Floyd pray for us in heaven forgive us
for the violence we did to him and for
the disgraceful lack of sorrow mourning
and remorse shown here referencing
something that Trump said but listen to
that may mr. Floyd pray for us in heaven
now note that among Catholics a saint is
anybody in heaven anybody in heaven is a
saint
so father James Martin has declared that
George Floyd is in heaven he sinked
Floyd st. George Floyd he has been
christened again I mean this this is I
keep I keep using the phrase I think
beyond parody but it really is may
George Floyd pray for us in heaven
but he's playing his part once again
doing as he's told like a good boy so
whether it is applause demanded of of us
or weeping or any other emotion and the
emotion will be assigned to us here's
the emotion you're supposed to
experience right now and demonstrate and
you damn well better demonstrate it but
whatever the emotion is the principle is
the same it's the same that applied to
that unfortunate but brave man who had
enough and sat down at that party
meeting in Soviet Russia the principle
is is never be the first to stop
applauding and that is all the more
reason why we should stop applauding
someone someone eventually has to sit
down and say enough I'm done I'm done
with this charade I won't participate I
won't do it I don't believe this
this is crazy this is irrational most of
the
pretending to believe it really don't
and I'm not going to pretend anymore
I won't applaud that is what we need to
say whatever the cost and we'll move on
to our news headlines in just a second
first though you know we've been telling
you about policy genius and if you're if
you've been waiting to get life
insurance well then the question is what
exactly are you waiting for you don't
wanna wait is one of those things we'll
put off we put off and put off until
it's too late with everything going on
right now a lot of people are asking if
it's even possible to buy life insurance
at all the short answer is yes it's very
possible you can buy life insurance
during a pandemic you can buy it anytime
you want and if you have loved ones
depending on your income you probably
should as an insurance marketplace pal
to genius is in contact with the life
insurance companies on their platform
every day they're keeping track of all
the changes in the marketplace so you
don't have to do that they're taking the
hard work doing it for you which means
they can get you covered quickly and for
the best price here's how it works
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find your best price this doesn't just
save a lot of legwork you also save at
$1500 or more a year using policy genius
to compare life insurance policies now
that means that you know you're saving
time it's a lot less complicated and
you're saving a lot of money fifty
hundred dollars a year is nothing to
sneeze at
think about what you could do with that
extra money so if you're one of the many
people looking to buy life insurance
right now but you're not sure where to
start head to policy genius com policy
genius we'll find you the best rate and
handle the process completely they'll
get you and your family protected and
hopefully give you one thing less to
worry about which i think is something
we could all use right now all right
news headlines that number one a statue
of Christopher Columbus in Richmond was
torn down by a mindless mob last night
they tore down the statue set the statue
on fire and then threw it into a lake
once again they were allowed to do this
they were allowed to destroy property
commit crime no attempt to enforce the
law was apparently made now listen if
you are not speaking out forcefully
against this kind of thing right now
then I don't know what to say about you
you're brain dead you're clueless
there is a rampaging mob tearing down
our history literally tearing it down
brick by brick statue by statue and and
you know what however you feel about the
person that the statue is supposed to
represent you should oppose a rampaging
mob tearing it down
you should oppose that on principle now
as far as that goes though let me say
this about Christopher Columbus
specifically I think I think more than
the principal when it comes to Columbus
you should oppose it being torn down
number one because we can't allow
rampaging mobs to do this kind of thing
number two because Christopher Columbus
deserves to have a statue now did he
commit atrocities yes he did this was a
brutal time across the world it was not
a racially racially enlightened time it
was it was a time when every single
person on earth in say the Year 1492
when Columbus is sailing the ocean blue
every single person on earth and 1492
every single person would be racist by
our standards today every single person
on earth no exceptions it is just
impossible it is actually impossible to
believe that there was anyone in 1492
existing on the planet with 21st century
Western ideas about race impossible
there was nobody okay that's that's
something we've keep in mind it was also
a time when slavery was commonplace
across the world not everybody supported
it thankfully most people probably did
and it was a commonplace institution
across the world it was a time when the
land was taken by conquest if you had
land and you wanted to keep it you had
to protect it if there was land and you
wanted to take it you took it if you
were able to it was a time when people
from different lands and tribes hated
each other
reflexively assumed the worst of each
other in fact we still live in that time
it's just that the tribes are different
now they're more ideological than racial
now Columbus was guilty of all of that
and more and the thing is no matter what
you say if you were born in the 15th
century you would have been a brutal
bigot also doesn't mean you would have
done everything Columbus did good and
bad but this much is a guarantee if you
were alive in 1492 you would be a brutal
bigot he just would be unless you have
the arrogance to claim that you would
have been the exception across everybody
else is one way but you you would have
been the enlightened one yes you would
have been the one who could see the
world you know who could who could have
a mindset that was 500 years ahead of
its time yes you yeah I'm sure you would
have right
those people tearing down the statues
yeah I'm sure I'm sure that they would
have been the exception right they would
have had the mindset 500 years ahead of
its time sure yeah I'm sure right now
does any of this excuse evil no but it
puts it in context and context is
important it's important to thinking
people it's important thinking
intelligent people with brains care
about context because it helps us decide
how to analyze how to see things but
these mobs are not comprised of thinking
people these are ungrateful ignorant
pompous brats who live in Western
civilization luxuriating in its comforts
enjoying the fruits of labor performed
by greater men than themselves while
hating those same men and claiming that
the achievements which they take for
granted and which make their lives so
easy and comfortable and wonderful and
joyful are nothing you know it's common
now to hear people say that Columbus
didn't really achieve anything because
this land was already occupied and he
didn't mean to find it so what are you
really that stupid that you think that
that makes it unimpressive he set sail
across an uncharted ocean thousands of
miles to find a part of the world that
that nobody in his world knew about and
he established a permanent settlement in
a hostile world wilderness and then
repeated that feat three more times that
he know where he was going exactly No
because this was a 15th and 16th century
didn't have GPS he didn't have the
Internet he didn't even have a map you
know I didn't have a map because guys
like Columbus created the map we needed
men like him to go out and sail around
and discover stuff so that we could have
maps that later generations could use so
that we could understand what the world
was like is that an achievement yes I
would say it is it's a greater
achievement than anything you will ever
do in your life or that I will ever do
and by the way this idea that it's not
impressive because people live there
already ok so in the future when a space
explorer sets out for a distant solar
system and on the way bumps into an
inhabited planet discovers a you know
life on another planet are we gonna say
that that achievement doesn't matter
that it's not impressive yeah whatever I
mean yeah I discovered a planet with
inhabited life intelligent life you know
3 billion miles away but he didn't even
mean to go there he was going to that
solar system over there what a [ __ ]
what a dummy is that we're gonna say
pretending that this event doesn't
radically transform our world in our
understanding our understanding of the
very very reality of the world we live
in is not as not now being transformed
because of this no I hope we would not
say that
and the comparison is 100% apt what
Columbus did was at least as impressive
and significant as discovering a new
planet in outer space in fact I would
say probably a lot more significant
weather it's more impressive I mean it's
you know that we could debate that is
that worthy of a statute yes I would say
it is until the non-contributing idiot
dumb brats tore it down and one other
one other point if again if you think
this isn't impressive ok then you know
just give it a shot I mean go to even
with all of your modern understanding of
everything you know you you understand
you know more about how the entire world
looks what the entire world looks like
than Columbus did not
you're smart but not because they're
smarter than he was but just because
guys like him told you what the world's
like but anyway even with that modern
understanding try to you know set off
you know in a ship from I mean anywhere
on the continent on the East Coast I
mean you just take to add the Outer
Banks of North Carolina let's say and
just just just head that away and try to
see if you can land on I don't know
Ireland okay these are all known areas
okay so you can see what you could do by
the way no GPS you don't get to have
that no map you don't get that either no
no help with satellites no radio so if
you get stranded out there you're
screwed you're dead so you're gonna know
going into this that there's a very good
chance you'll die very good chance you
didn't do it anyway and see if you can
make it I mean see if you can even hit
anywhere on the other side of the world
yes just try to try to make effect I'll
give you the entirety of Europe and and
in Africa and West Africa I'll give you
all of that just try to hit any part of
that without dying or like running into
Antarctica I bet you couldn't even come
close to doing it I bet you'd be dead in
two days and so would I so impressive
can we be impressed yeah I think we can
be impressed important discovery yeah I
would say important but then again if
you're not impressed with Western
civilization if you if you think it was
founded by Marauders and rapists and and
we have no right to be here you are free
to leave anytime you want you're free to
do that no one's gonna stop you and in
fact we talk about applauding that is
one thing that I will genuinely
sincerely applaud I will give you a
standing ovation as you take your
ungrateful ass out of here
okay number two HBO max the new
streaming service has dropped
gone with the wind the film classic
because its depiction of race is not
woke enough by our standards today so we
have entered the
burning face now and since I've been
reading great works of literature on the
show today let me read this from 1984
George Orwell of course and there's a
relevant passage says every record has
been destroyed or falsified every book
rewritten every picture has been
repainted every statue in street
building has been renamed every date has
been altered and the process is
continuing day by day and minute by
minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except an endless present in which the
party is always right what more needs to
be said that's where we are this is not
Orwellian anymore it's just reality
number three here's an important PSA
from susan meister who's apparently she
says a PhD in religious studies also a
blue check on twitter very important
person podcast host we're all very
important to podcasts host you know
anyway she says in a since deleted tweet
she says white women stop calling your
friend group your tribe its
appropriating Native American culture
and also it's really really annoying
appropriating and of course Susan is
white herself which which you could
probably already guess appropriating to
say the word tribe yeah very very good
point there Karen I mean when I read
about the tribes of Israel in the Bible
I'm always shocked and horrified that
biblical writers in the Middle East
three thousand years ago were
appropriating from Native American
culture very very very horrible stuff
unless of course tribe is actually an
English word with Latin roots that
originally referred to the divisions of
Roman society alright I think that's it
I think that's what it is glad we could
clear that up
number four George Floyd's funerals
mentioned was yesterday buried in a
golden casket as all saints deserve to
be al Sharpton of course was on the
scene he gave the eulogy now usually the
eulogy is given by a family member or
close friend or the local pastor someone
who knew the deceased or at least had
some kind of personal connection to him
or his family and therefore could
actually talk about him and pay tribute
to him and his life in a meaningful way
that's normally how the eulogy is
handled al Sharpton I don't think knew
George Floyd never met him but he gave
the eulogy and here's how that went all
this fan that was
it's justice oh it's nice to see some
people change their mind Kenny the NFL
said Yale maybe we was wrong
football players maybe they did have the
right to peacefully protest well don't
apologize give Colin Kapernick a job
back don't come with some empty apology
take a man's livelihood strip a man down
of his talents and four years later when
the whole world is marching all of a
sudden you go and do a FaceTime talk
about you sorry
minimizing the value of our lives
you sorry been repaid the damage you did
to the career you stood down cuz when
Colin took a knee he took it for the
families in this filming and we don't
want an apology we want him repair
[Applause]
okay so we've got a guy who didn't know
George Floyd giving a eulogy for George
Floyd by talking about Colin Kaepernick
and Roger Goodell great it makes a lot
of sense doesn't it now as as to the the
question of why Colin Kaepernick doesn't
have a job
it's actually because Colin Kaepernick
is not a very good football player he
was a mediocre football player when he
left the game like four years ago and he
hasn't gotten better since you know you
don't go from mediocre athlete and then
you don't play for four years and you
come back and you're a superstar so
that's the reason he's not it's not it's
it's really not a mystery if Colin
Kaepernick was you know had the talent
of Lamar Jackson let's say he would be
playing right now I don't care what he
did or said I can guarantee you that a
superstar quarterbacks are gonna find a
job it doesn't matter what they do what
they say how much of a jerk they are
doesn't matter Colin Kaepernick is not a
superstar quarterback never was will
never be and so he's just not worth the
headache that comes with him that's why
he doesn't have a job but none of this
has anything to do with George Floyd of
course so why is this being brought up I
know of course I know why these are
these are all rhetorical questions I
know why it's being brought up I know
why Al Sharpton is there al Sharpton is
there because he's a race hustling
opportunistic creep you know so that
that kind of I guess solves that mystery
number five finally the LA Galaxy which
apparently is a soccer team because we
apparently have soccer teams in this
country for reasons that are unclear to
me they have released Serbian soccer
star Aleksandr khatai they released him
over offensive Instagram posts about the
rioters now here's the the kicker pun
intended they were not his posts they
were his wife's posts so his wife sent
out a couple of Instagram posts that
were deemed offensive and racist and so
they fire him for what his wife said
that's where we are now his
you don't just get fired for your own
wrong think you can get fired for
someone you know they're wrong think but
this is kind of interesting because I
guess what we're telling Alexander
khatai is that he should have controlled
his wife better I guess so he's being
fired for not controlling everything his
wife doesn't says that's why he's fired
I don't know what the conversation was
when they pull them into the office but
essentially it boils down to you know
you need to get a handle on your wife
and controller that's why you're fired I
mean that's what they're saying
I'm not saying that they're saying that
they're gonna fire a guy because of what
his wife says you're blaming him for
what his wife says the only way you
could do that is if you are saying it
was his responsibility to control what
she says that that to me doesn't seem
very happy that doesn't seem up to the
woke standards but this this again you
see where the poor feminists they always
Louvre that lose out they're just going
further and further down they're
descending the ranks of victims the
victim hierarchy they're getting they're
getting booted from their spot left and
right further and further down the
ladder eventually feminists are gonna be
no better than conservative white men
you guys are gonna be with us soon
enough I mean welcome welcome down here
to the pit because you know they they
get soup all of their their agenda their
priorities constantly getting superseded
by more important victim groups all
right let's move on to our daily
cancellation speaking of with speaking
of trouble with with wives I've got to
talk about that in just a second before
I do you know there's so much going on
this year in the news and we've been
talking about some of that today on the
show and then of course the big problems
you have the left-wing media constantly
pushing their agenda instead of doing
actual reporting when you can't get the
real story you have to go outside the
narrative and just get the facts so if
you're a political junkie set on getting
both sides of the story you can get a
reader's pass today from daily wire calm
you'll get access to exclusive op-eds
from us your podcast host as well as
guest writers many interesting people
in-depth analysis from our daily wire
reporters on topics you know ranging all
across the news spectrum this membership
is it's here is already a bargain at
three dollars a month but if you join
today you get your first month for 99
cents okay you also get access to our
mobile app you receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content as well as you can join
the community of daily wire members who
are actively commenting and discussing
our content with each other that's
mobile ad free access to all of the
daily wire news exclusive op-eds and
more on our mobile app all for the low
price of one dollar and best of all your
dollars are getting you the news you
need without the left to spin so head
over to daily wire calm slash subscribe
and join today okay for our daily
cancellation and this guy's you know is
very hard for me always to do this
deeply painful but I have no choice I
have to cancel my wife again and let me
tell you what she did this time first a
little bit of background to things you
should know about me if you don't
already one is that I get into these
little kicks where I order an obscene
number of books from Amazon in the span
of a couple of weeks as I'm trying to
restock my reading supply for the month
months ahead so it's it's sort of like a
squirrel storing up food for the winter
except this is the nerd version of that
and I've been on one of those kicks
recently so I've been ordering a lot of
books and this annoys my wife okay for
some reason doesn't like the fact that
there are six new books coming to the
house every day
she thinks that that's a little bit
overdone I don't know why second fact is
that I am an apiarist or beekeeper to
you common folk my wife is canceled for
publicly shaming me on both of these
counts now here's the tweet that she
sent out last night it says I can't then
with laughing face emojis her use of
emojis by the way is a secondary reason
for canceling her anyways anyways I I
can't
a nice light reading came for you today
talking to me helped myself to opening
your Amazon package
and then it's a picture of a book I
ordered called honeybee democracy about
the social structure of the honeybee
hive and particularly about the
decision-making process of a honey bee
swarm after it because it will honey bee
swarm after a faction of the bees leave
the hive with the deposed Queen and
they're in search of a new place to live
and this book really gets into how they
make that decision and how communication
and navigation works within a honey bee
swarm yes I bought an entire book on
that subject fascinating stuff I read a
couple chapters last night I thought it
was very interesting but my wife is
literally laughing at me publicly over
this and she even she takes she takes
screenshots of the different pages of
the book and then opposed to them to
like making fun of it because she finds
it absurd for some reason that a man
would read a book about bees or for
books about bees in the past week in my
case so let's go through this now let's
list all of the micro and macro
aggressions my wife has committed
against me and not for the first time I
born she opened my package invasion of
privacy unconstitutional federal crime I
could have her taken away in cuffs by
federal agents if I wanted to I could
call the FBI right now and report that
is a federal crime to tamper with mail
second she be shames me she shames me
for my interest in bees and if it seems
like I'm taking that too personally you
know if you don't understand
well well here's what you need to
understand that in my community among
those who identify as beekeepers we have
for so long had our identities
marginalized and trivialized
you know this is one of the reasons why
people are very hesitant often to come
out as beekeepers I'll never forget the
time when I worked up the courage to
finally come out and gather my family
and friends around and and tell them you
know I have something I need to tell you
it's very important to me I would think
about this a long time I'm a beekeeper
is a very important and intimate moment
in my life and this is the
this is not something I'm choosing to be
this this is my identity this is my
truth and I'm gonna live it openly and
publicly and I'm not gonna be afraid of
Who I am to have my own wife making a
mockery of my deepest truth authorizing
me erasing my identity denying me the
right to exist and be free well that's
just that's that's literally the worst
thing that has ever happened to anyone
ever
and all of this while my wife is a
chicken farmer
she has chickens look are you really
gonna shame me over my B's when you have
chickens do you want to get into this
competition I don't think you do look at
a beehive 50,000 bees working as one
seamless unit a superorganism graceful
and industrious and productive meanwhile
I saw one of her chickens the other day
eat his own poop and then run into a
wall so I don't think this is a debate
that she wants to have I really don't
and that's why she's canceled
hopefully the lesson has finally been
learned and then I'm really sorry I
gotta keep airing dirty laundry on this
show but this is my safe space and my
outlet for talking about the persecution
that I suffer even in my own own
all right let's we'll wrap it up there
thanks for watching and listening
everybody Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 candy companies issues
statements on the race riots never
thought I would say that the crime rate
soars and the experts changed their tune
on coronavirus yet again check it out on
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
you